all right christine
christine uh where you from where'd you
grow up
i grew up in um
wichita falls texas wichita falls texas
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were a kid um
yeah one um
left when i was quite young but
how old were you when you left um
like 12 i believe 12. what was going on
at home that
that you left at 12. um
i was forced to leave home uh
because i had a young child and um
there's a lot of fighting and arguing at
home
you got pregnant at 12 who is the father
um his name is
so you had the baby
and where'd you go at 12 years old with
a baby
um i moved to
denver for a while um
your family wouldn't help you no
what was your childhood like it was um
it was a bit rough at times it uh
was there's a lot of arguing and strife
at home
you know but uh any abuse like sexual
abuse or anything like that
yeah some yeah
with who with your relatives
so you moved to denver as a mother 12
years old yeah and what'd you do then
um i did my best to um
raise my oldest daughter and uh
i um
i struggled something but i
yeah um
i miss it was rough but
but you kept the baby um i ended up
giving the baby up for adoption because
she was getting raped by
her uh grandpa
this is the the father's
[Music]
and then where'd you go from there um
i left for a while to texas like back to
texas
for a bit but um
how far did you go in school sixth grade
drugs are a part of your life today yeah
they are that's
uh crystal meth when did that start for
you
or when a drug use sophie when i was
like
11. who introduced you to drugs at 11
um my parents
so your parents are addicts
so today you're living on skid row i am
you're in a tent or you're just on the
street
just really on the street right now
you know nowhere really to go
what are you doing to support yourself
um
typically you know uh
um what a lot of the girls do
i guess in a way you know
do you have any contact with your family
at all i do not not right now
you do when's the last time you spoke to
anyone it's been
quite some time and you have other
children too
i do how many kids do you have
um other than marissa uh
i have five three five and did you raise
the other ones
um one was um with his father
and um and i raised um
the last four but yeah
how old are you today 41 41. your kids
range in age from what to what um the
oldest would have
been 30
maybe 30 and the youngest 13 i believe
do you talk with any of your kids no not
right now
living here on the street is a terrible
life what kind of stuff have you been
through
i've been through pretty much everything
like
um right uh
just a bunch of uh trauma i guess
what's the hardest part of your life
right now um
[Music]
not permanently like having
um
like availability to be able to like
take
showers and like it's it's rough
do you have any friends um
a few like you know um
that there just people on the street
do you feel like you were ever loved in
your life um
yeah like by um
by uh friends you know
do you have anyone in your life that you
feel you can trust
um friends on the street are not always
the most
trustworthy the best rate i know some
it's rough
but yeah
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your 41 years
um that uh
to never like give up hope on anything
especially you know even when terrible
things happen it seems
you get depressed sometimes i do
it must be tough yeah
do you feel sometimes you're just
repeating the same life your parents had
yeah it feels like a generational curse
right
it does anyway i just see it as
bad role models that you had as a kid
looking back at your childhood is there
anything you wish
had been different um
that uh
i would have um done better with the
kids i believe
you know like you never feel like
sometimes you want to be the perfect
parent and it's almost uh
impossible but yeah i think that would
be the one thing i regret
do you ever feel like life is just
unfair yeah
absolutely um
like not being able to
have freedom like to just be happy and
like in love with whom you wish and
um afraid of uh
like crazy burdens you know what i mean
do you feel betrayed by members of your
of your family
[Applause]
in a way um
i've been hurt by them but uh
not like
are you still hopeful i am you are it's
good yeah
what do you hope for i hope to um
letting people to
dance and sing and like do this stuff
it'd be nice
but yeah that's what i'm that's what i
really hope for you know what i mean
what was the best time of your life the
best time of my life would have been
um probably
um
um probably
when i was um like
16. it was probably
um being an assistant kindergarten
teacher
like
that was probably the best time in my
life was helping out the kids like
but yeah have you had jobs yeah i've
been an accounting clerk
um i've uh
i've um
won't take gas stations and little
things like that but
is this the worst time of your life
right now yeah it's pretty rough
yeah absolutely like hot
and just yeah
do you feel like you're worthy of a
better life than this oh so
yeah i think everyone is
right but sometimes people some people
feel like they just don't deserve it
and they belong here on the street yeah
been homeless for how long for about a
year now
does it feel like home not truly
like
[Applause]
i hope for a better future than just
living on the streets
you know
what's the most dangerous thing you've
encountered being raped
by some friends i guess
how do you see yourself changing your
life and getting away from here
um getting cleaned up and like uh
like i don't know doing the best that i
can you know
[Applause]
i need to at least uh get a little start
somehow
you know put money away to
get an apartment who knows i have no
idea something
you know i have no idea
what personality trait do you have that
helps you survive this
this street life
um just having a positive attitude i
guess
you know you stay positive yeah good for
you
all right christine well thank you for
talking with me you're welcome good luck
with
getting out of here thank you thank you
very much
you